yep on to the next game oh we know nihei
okay let's go for it I don't really have
any deeper knowledge about this poll is
called ni and why flat from the US aim I
really have no idea do you play f4 in
this position 93 maybe it's got push up
you form to exchange the knight on f3
and then go push up to g5 no idea so
this looks so really slow
yeah it is slow okay or is it an idea to
really blast open the queenside at at
once with before yeah I try this it
takes on before now I go nite a form in
order to go to be six and we crept
captured before later yeah of course
this was some this was possible
yeah I know this looks strange from a
position of point of view but he's
really completely underdeveloped and the
position open that opens up now the
night on f8 really rg8 really needs a
couple of moves to to get into play huh
interesting but how does he plan to to
keep this porn isn't this just just
really weak
so I first give the check and then drop
back to a2 Wow
okay assembly don't understand what he's
doing hauck of course he couldn't play
Queen d7 at all because they taken
Bishop g4 then this was even what's even
worse then I'm and then I thought for
black okay now d 6 if it takes Queen f7
I could also take on 86 first it takes
with the Queen Queen c7 yeah but I am
pleasantly don't want to spoil this
chance to get the King really out in the
open this must be good for white if it
takes now maybe I rocked you one King
Seven Quincy five check it's also
completely devastating I guess is this
winning simply check
group 2 6 Jess check black Brazil yeah
yeah just he just spent far too much
time here i guess i guess it's certainly
okay up to this point but i'm really not
sure about about this move maybe you
should just take and play nagi to have
62 to get some pieces developed this is
really coming quickly now of course you
can defend better that's no question but
this already really looks dangerous I
think here's to is to play very accurate
moves computer actually gives Queen dat
am c 3 yeah that's of course
compensation provide but maybe not much
more yeah but it would have been really
easier for him to just develop or
normally instead of playing on the night
to f8